hah what's up that other part was just a
test
happy Friday everybody I'm Eric that's
Rob hi we are checking out a game that
you really like and have just started
kind of playing I guess you saw the
preview bill too but you and Peter have
been advocating it we talked about it on
the lobby but today we're gonna find out
more about the game echo-y you guys
should play it and what it's all about
Rob's gonna be doing that cuz he loved
with the this game here so I love this
game I've been dying for this moment
yeah I'm super excited and also Eric
this is the coolest menus that is
creeping me the hell out whoa quit is
red huh yeah they don't want you to and
I don't want to eat it okay cool so what
is this game it's a sci-fi horror third
person game made by some of the devs
from IO who worked on hitman the last
hitman this is the company is the ultra
ultra and this is their first game it's
called echo okay what is this game about
it's a third person so I find horror
game okay where you the tagline is the
enemy is you in that you go through a
series of stages where you have clones
or replicants called echos and they
mimic what you did in the previous light
cycle and we'll see that in play but
swing you are in turn battling yourself
I wanted to open up with this because
this game is so awesome I can go back
and forth between things I've done to
have not been am very close but I want
to show off the intro to kind of set the
tone of this awesome game so let's do it
let's do it
should I turn this up I feel like I
should you should audio audio up we're
currently playing on
you should get off the surface - what a
strange place
it's impressive
really so I'm on this planet okay it's
experience hey what's up guys - all the
peoples are saying hi in YouTube chat
the voice acting has been spectacular
her name is Leslie Jones she was Ingrid
from Game of Thrones the redhead the
famous line you know nothing Jon Snow
that's her voice you're the character
it's called n-nice it's okay it's that
shirt though yeah Craig Sager that's
what the shirt Rahul yes Rob has played
a bunch so he should be able to showcase
a bunch of cool stuff to you guys and
how it works
mechanics he's gonna potentially even
try the hard mode which he hasn't tried
though I didn't give that a go at the
end and I sleep hungry and I actually as
I was messing around with the hut I
noticed that there was a locked mode so
I would imagine if you beat the game
there might be even a harder one this is
$30 right $22 just a steal on Steam it's
coming to ps4 sometime in October what
Mike said was right it was originally it
was originally going to be launched on
ps4 at the same time but hasn't delays
it gives me another reason to pimp it
again so so I have these cells to which
are reflecting on like mike-mike or
ability so I have a gun which comes
later but I just kind of wanted to set
the tone here plan it like this is like
really mysterious game this is the
planet I'm arriving at there is a reason
for me to do it the on the on my back is
this cube of a loved one I have that I'm
basically my goal you find out early on
is to revive my my loved one and she and
his led to believe that this planet can
do that it's kind of actually the voice
so anyways actually this is all I really
wish goood wants to know what's the hook
for you rob is it the puzzles or the
combat or some combination of both
everything it's everything ok we're
gonna see a little bit more Rob trauma I
just wanted this yeah now we're gonna
kind of go into where most of the stuff
happens right which is the palace yep ok
so you'll understand real quickly or
after that I tested this level because
it's a great way of setting setting the
example of why or how you are fighting
yourself okay are there multiple ways to
then beat set level that is slow or
pretty linear there it's a very much a
you know each puzzle I want to say is
yeah so look at they automatically see
me but
they're not crossing the water okay they
haven't learned that yet right and they
kill me what we're gonna look they like
look at the water and look at me though
yeah it's real creepy there is
definitely some poor elements so yet so
they they are not you're like okay right
the more I sprint the more they're gonna
learn it's it's really any action for
most parts and then so the palace so see
that see that hologram yeah the palace
just noticed that that you ate a grape
it's like oh I should eat so is that
like a way to stall them because exactly
there are pianos there are pianos there
are harps that you can use so like
you'll like play play a piano and then
you'll like the next cycle you'll hear
them so here we go here's an example and
the cycles are only determined by
information it's not they're not set in
time that time the more the more
Holograms you see the more closer to
that life cycle is gonna cycle okay so
look at this I got to do it so they just
learn how to vault and touch water
and sort of spring and and sprint and
walk or like jog
so am I trying to go try to go this way
well just learned again my stamina is
really low and they have a reason for it
I've been in cryo for a century and the
suit is like helping me so here we go
this is the dark the dark cycle now I
can do whatever I want and the and the
palace will not be able to like learn
write or download the essential right
there's the problem now cycles gonna
come these dark cycles are or their
their sense oh hey what's up
so my stamina like I can't do all these
things stuff I uh no so now here we go
the problem is that now they can okay so
I get I get one chance to fight them
away now I'm red so they touch me again
I'm dead it gets gets real hard I'm kind
of Marcela and guesser says looks
awesome it is what just advertise a TBS
I'm not sure if it was chip it did come
out earlier this week was Tuesday right
yeah yeah yeah so so and also see these
globes here yeah they refill my cells
there which allow me to fire okay and I
take fall damage one because I'm weak
I've been in cryo for a century and the
suit can only its power basically will
help fall damage but I can only do so
many vaults
bungle Blanc's see the part of like
you're not seeing all the game yet all
of the strategy that is involved that
Rob is just kind of showing you some of
the basic components but it sounds like
it does get extremely like crazy and I'm
sure hardmode gonna be even crazier yeah
I would imagine hard mode is like
proximity of one of one they can you
know see you how much health I have and
so these things here the more I collect
I believe it's every six of those orbs I
collect every time I collect six I get a
new cell so that's again a factor of my
ammo I got to go back F they don't mind
the water anymore they're learning
Gonzalo Hernandez saying I love the art
oh yeah me too really pretty go to sleep
so that's what happens no and and choke
me out you'll see all right what's that
little wand you got on so that's a key I
just picked up so they're each each a
little area has a different form of
puzzle sometimes it's like collect
twelve orbs you know return a key to a
door to move on okay it's a downloaded
more sneaking oh and even more so again
these are all deterrent order there also
anytime it's a yellow is they can
they're on a path and the more whenever
it's yellow it's caution because they
can see me by and still being perfected
if I'm still in there like decorating
go out anything goes so I now this is
where you like to basically well it's
where I see myself like generally where
you use your weapon and you want to like
what grass but it's where you like
aren't using stealth you want to get
through [ __ ] so scary is are you
vulnerable for it oh you'll see slowly
it slowly goes away just right behind me
so the thing is like the more I sprint
you think like because they're they're
really slow but the more I sprint like
if I like there are times where I forgot
how much I sprinted so like in the dark
cycle it's so scary you like yum-yum-yum
in the dark cycle like they don't I
don't they'll surprise you like they
won't necessarily just like always be
sprinting but like they can so it's like
it's just that you're not expecting it
right like they're smart they're so
smart so like I'll be like oh you're not
even sprinting no problem and then I'll
turn around and she's on a full-on
sprint it's dark and so I can't see that
well until like she be like a melee kill
may shoot a lot of people in chat I have
a 2k totally maxed it out here in the
office I hate going home and playing on
something less than that it looks so
good when it's mad so John's man yes
every time he's in the palace or well
most of the the game is in the palace
but during the light cycle anything he
does and you see like kind of like a
brief like hologram or like kind of
ghost effect it basically is the palace
learning what Rob is doing either eating
grapes we haven't played a piano but
apparently that is a thing sneaking
takedowns sprinting they weren't
crossing the water earlier and the
moment you crossed it oh look at this
this is the one that I first had where I
was like this isn't a big deal they're
in these rooms and then you start
realizing oh [ __ ]
they've learned we'll look at they can't
get out now but they're about to so now
it's like oh my god
time to move so is that because you open
it like they learned that you open the
door so they know how to open the door
now so now I'm when I first said this
was like oh my god I have to get through
this area quick this is where like I
would be like if I haven't well
obviously you played this level but this
first time must have been like
nerve-racking
oh sure oh like if there's anyone else
there or if you know you're safe there
was so many of them in this room holy
crap
oh and it only takes three of them in if
there are three of them near me they can
kill me immediately and like as the game
ramps up they do get like smarter and
smarter I would say guys you progress
spurt yeah like overall I felt like
bailing on so let's try this out oh no
they know they know how to shoot good
and they heard it so this is but this
will be next cycle right right slight
slight exact oh then oh she's sprinting
see you not all them sprint not all of
them sprained Eric's okay so dude not
all of them shoot too then right oh now
they know how to vault so yeah this what
I just did yep oh great kick
try to make out with me Oh
there's two on there yeah Devin hum hum
Ola saying it feels like it's more of a
thriller than a horror game yeah I would
say it's more like yeah I don't know
tell you it's like that fine line like
sister versus like it's not like horror
in the traditional sense of like oh
there's a monster you know it's more of
like the setting and the fact that
they're all the same they're your clone
essentially right yeah I would say like
the surprises and like I mean there's a
there's a spoiler that wouldn't show is
like I don't know like the the kind of
lore of these echoes I find is very old
for ish but it's not like your classic
like dark deep core but it's like an
unsettling whole its attention yeah it's
like never knowing what's around the
corner yeah feel or like even in that
case it was like pitch black and you ran
into like five of your echos looks like
holy crap that's real scary
yeah at the ant that ambient audio is so
cool to how it ramps up like everything
I do queues are really important and and
really make this game special to me to
the death scene is pretty much always
the same though right like it could be
different okay okay
but yeah it's generally mostly that like
yeah you just get caught right and you
don't know you become that one game
it's blinking out of my my head now the
one where you could like make clones or
yourself to like get through puzzles but
then like there was like the morality of
like oh did I just kill a bunch of
myself
sounds familiar though like a spacey
game you had like a spacesuit I can't
remember the name of the game escaping
me right now
yeah shook nine yay we're not gonna go
too much into the story spoilers so
Rob's just mainly gonna showcase the
story the story is fairly light but
everything's like but it makes sense
right legging we don't want to give that
kind of stuff away sure like I would say
like the story there's there's a longs
our set up story and then throughout
it's like bits of VO dialogues during
but like to set up in the beginning and
and periodically is is all about like
getting to the end and finding out like
you know that there's a mystery
throughout and like I haven't gone to
the end so I'm like dying to know like
again like what this palace is all about
why I'm here exactly like my history oh
[ __ ]
so that's Rob Rob is the gentleman with
the blonde hair I'm Eric thank you guys
for tuning in we are playing echo on PC
currently I think it's at 20 to roughly
22 dollars on sale right on Steam it
will be obvious for it will eventually
be on ps4 in October it's this puzzle
kind of sci-fi horror in a way depending
on how you look at
a game or your I can also tag enemies it
does remind me of hitman to do her eyes
are white it is creepy so right now he's
in the like dark cycle where he can
pretty much do anything in the palaces
and palaces the place he's in is it
learning what he's doing but now that
he's in the light cycle it's gonna learn
and adapt all the things that he's doing
and those clones or echoes will then try
to do that to him and someone drop a
question which I actually don't use up
there is a stealth stunned it's like
kinda like a riot a riot gun that will I
use the right button on my controller
and it's like a reminds me of the the
wasn't the weapon in Minority Report
it's just like okay like a riot control
like throws back multiple enemies which
you know what think about it thinking
about it like that's pretty useful so so
my so my my main weapon actually is like
think of it as a railgun I can you're
kind of taught early on that you can
line them up and yeah I don't shoot I
can shoot through a minute it says what
is that an eraser see the reticle
changes that means I can get two kills
here
so you'd want to do that as well but the
ride is more of like a like an AoE right
like I look at it push away get away
from me and I keep forgetting I had that
we're definitely not all eight games
this is one of these cool games not like
observer was this year all you did Oh
double team kind of like observer that
we just kind of want to show two more
people to get that on their people's
radars there's a lot of good games out
this year obviously but this is one that
Rob and Peter so much kind of saw early
and really enjoyed and he's still
enjoying it so it's able to be able to
showcase some of these and honestly yeah
and I honestly like no we're not getting
paid but like I this game has not gone
much traction and and I don't know it
just doesn't have enough marketing so
like that's kind of a cool part about
our job is like it's like discover games
and you know try to like show people
like how awesome they are and this is a
case Josh asked what stops me from white
waiting out a light cycle
oh yeah going in I was under the
understanding that like Oh lights lights
idle time light cycles like 30 seconds
the light cycle will only end if I give
it information so you can't just wait it
out or something they're doing stuff to
them that then triggers the next thing
right which is which is kind of like the
coolest part rights the palace is like
no you gotta give me something
you're gonna stealth you're gonna shoot
you're gonna do something I'll see some
great yeah I got I got to teach these
echoes something everything makes
perfect sense don't you see
as well it's all tied to the blackout
cycles when the lights are on the palace
keeps track of my actions registering
what I do with those icy ghosts after
sometime it will reboot - that's what's
causing the blackouts I get no ghosts
when the lights are out so my guess is
that the palace is blind while it's
rebooting when the lights come back on
their abilities match my actions from
the previous light cycle without to
explain why they wouldn't cross the
water up there I didn't touch any water
in the light cycle before I reached them
yes yes that's exactly what they are
damned
but that was weird though okay so didn't
you touch water like above but then you
did like you got to another water part
was on the end didn't you a question I
don't know I think that's kind of like
the the case of like different areas I
think it's just the area so like yeah
for the most part it's pretty linear
like that
she showed that that was it I used to
list done yeah so you're again I showed
earlier the like outside so I'm calling
I'm kind of going back outside so in the
beginning you're kind of you're climbing
down to get in and so now I'm like deep
within this the whole planet is
basically the pallet the palace right
you sound like naming them explains
everything to me the logic of it all
only makes the whole thing more absurd
someone intentionally designed it to be
framerate kind of chucks here I will say
that I'm hoping Bill had some tactics
because I've had some problems problems
like that Holmes
oddly enough like I feel like the game
doesn't register 360 controllers that
well like I found Xbox one could just be
a Pakistan gaming the red cube on the
back of the protagonist here is a loved
one which she is trying to bring back to
life which is why she's here to be
anyway that's right let's move around
scored another check out another level
and show kind of this is what I love is
like how quickly I can like load and go
back and forth and it's that that you I
I love it so let's do let's go to
different chapter
oh my god lucky go into this room this
one oh this one this area took me so
long they're all just like I'm trying to
get like get into the middle there
they're like if you alert more than
three three or more you're just you're
screwed you just screwed so you have to
like I have other abilities which I'm
not using it which is like I can call or
whisper for one and learn my way or I
can shout and get a whole group moving
madeline asking is there any way to turn
the echoes against each other no no all
you can do is try to do things to
distract them like eating grapes and
other things like maybe playing a piano
I think we might see some piano action
oh yeah more action more harps
so if you notice that Palace is kind of
changing like a little architecture but
like obviously color and there are
plants that will now let you know it
started here yeah what started yeah
chandeliers what started as uh I already
see me
what started as you know a very sterile
palace and kind of like chains all and
there's a reason for it which I won't
say like the palaces is like a character
in itself which is cool yeah I wonder
what insane mode is like there's I'm
think I think there's like the HUD
there's a HUD difficulty I think you can
turn off like playing yeah playing this
game without HUD I mean you have pretty
solid audio cues but like playing with
out huh ballsy where am I going here so
I have a scan which cool with the scan
is then my HUDs gone so I have to wait
for the for the bubble of the scan to
come back so you're kind of vulnerable
in that respect so I have it what you
just saw oh I thought it remembered my
call I haven't heard him to speak that's
just it's just registering my crouching
or I can yell hey I am definitely not
raised gum I know who you're talking
about though black ass
and there are collectibles in the game
like it's funny I do want to go back and
get them because they are tied to the
story like the more you get the more the
encrypted message oh oh yeah oh but no
oh that's other thing all the those ammo
okay all the those globes I've been
picking up all those turn off in some
areas do have save points Oh like the
green that teal that teal glow those are
the only things they can pick up those
are the ones that I can like progress my
and upgrade light my cells so now I have
three cells four cells excuse me now
nope five Josh Hall wants to know
without spoiling do too much do you
level up get new weapons or abilities
just just it just your cells nothing
nothing really else which I don't know
I'm okay with some people like like well
I know there was a our reviewer Justin
Clark oh that [ __ ] so I don't know so
that's a collectible no you can know
about it as far as I know you touch it
and you can start a blackout immediately
so I I think and then it goes away so
it's kind of like a weird tool I didn't
really help much though I kind of did
so fault oh okay
how big is the game I would say I know
of our reviewer finished it in seven
hours I'm on our 10 maybe even longer
alright that Marcel saying this game
seems very
it's ultimately you're playing against
yourself right which is like that's the
cool part so like you can kind of
determine how crazy these although I
here to say that you have to do so this
is a save and in some areas where
there's like tons of globes I can like I
can kind of look through it member like
in hell-blade there's like you know like
I didn't dimension like I can kind of
like see all the Globes or objectives
but touching back on what our reviewer
said it which I can understand and
somewhat agree with is that it you might
find the pals to get boring as a setting
but it's kind of all you see like you do
kind of just see the same architecture
but I find like the changing of color
and like atmosphere and lighting
subtlety the subtleties of it like is
engaging for me enough and like in I
think there are six chapters with like
you know six or seven missions in each
the later chapters like change
significantly where it's like you're
looking at something really different
because you're getting deeper and deeper
into look like the core of the planet
each chapter ends with life and starts
with a with an elevator Trek and like
you wake up and you hear the London is
the a I use you hear talking he goes
like good sheep egg passes out oh so
these are globes like pick up well but
just the hard time doing it
the treks you did London be like you
just traveled like 300 kilometres she's
like yeah like you get the sense of
scale which is kind of cool
but see these are globes this is very
hitman like I can like use them to kill
or I can use them to distract oh is that
noise
I use my scan to to like pinpoint
they're like these kind of collectibles
again those the more I get the more of
the ending level encryption is
understandable it's like a bunch of text
that's kind of yeah now it knows how to
murder yeah
oh there's piano oh so I not there's no
point of playing out because they won't
play and I've had times we're like I'm
about to die and then ends and it ends
just in time
oh these are lifesavers sometimes the
areas like again there's like collect
like 20 orbs and it takes a long time
damn and I've had to reset like a 20
minute run a couple times and you show
up in the scan as well yeah basically
actually I can do this okay oh that's
perfect
don't turn around don't turn around
don't they know how to take down now
they do I saw a tweet of a guy like
taking down someone and then got taken
down himself I've never really had I've
had a habit not that often maybe because
I'm just super good hey let's do this
kids got a cannon some sweet tunes
okay sleep and of course on every new
cycle the enemies respond oh yeah oh
yeah I shot it
alright so let's see she I'll hide I
want to hear him play count me in a bad
spot
see you again yeah
[Music]
so like each area is really well done
where there's like the tools are laid
out like there was one area was like
there are so many people and I have to
distract them and the game like is smart
to leave these multitude of ways of
doing so so like if you can find a way
to like trigger a harp or a piano then
they'll like move away from like the
goal or like an area I found out did you
do this to these the house just to give
you a quick kind of rundown how it works
is right now you're the protagonist
obviously and you're trying to make it
through this palace because you have an
objective that we're not going to talk
too much about and so he's trying to
progress through house but the thing is
there are echoes or clones of us in this
palace and everything you do they're
learning in the light cycle which is
where he's at right now it eventually
goes dark and that allows them to do
things that the palace will not learn
however so an example is that I in that
last cycle I did not open a door so they
actually weren't able to get through me
sight but now next light cycle they
would pay well to get through that door
if you were to be chased through there
so that's kind of the premise a little
bit how the game works like a very like
basic level but yeah and like I
personally have never had if there's any
other game I can't think of it but like
I've never had my brain kind of
consistently like working and though in
the way of like every action you do you
want to remember because you want to be
able to and the next cycle remember how
to counter it and it's like it's really
like cool and it feels like a healthy
like brain activity it's it's stressful
but like it's challenging I just really
enjoy that yeah someone in twitch chat'
to mention like it's like a really cool
okay yep see that's why so if you fire
your weapon they fire they have now
learned to fire the weapon I believe is
it coming on Xbox too or is it just
people I just know a ps4 okay so right
now on PC but also gonna be out on ps4
next month oh not sure about Xbox oh now
I just fired for no reason not good okay
yeah went there lay right next to you
like there's not much you can do unless
you can like quickly react and push it
away
well that's think 2 is pushing kills my
stamina okay so like you know that's why
it's sprinting in like pushing all you
always want to have some stamina ready
to do that red eight there is a story
I'm not sure about cutscenes I didn't
really see any cutscenes um no there's a
will there's cutscenes in beginning no
there aren't really any cutscenes Matt
Marcel they are constantly learning so
it's all the light cycles so now I don't
know how to can hear the the kind of
like yeah the three the kind of freezing
digital freeze almost but anytime that
and that a hologram that's when like
that's what they learned
yep booth so big and new and grapes oh I
could double grapes give you stamina we
see that yellow bar above my cells so
that doesn't read it it does regen
always but you could be real desperate
sometimes you can't really wait out
cycles it's all information just all
face off of information so you have to
be doing things for you to trigger the
dark you know I just realized what these
black areas are is oh kill me kill me
these black areas yeah do an auto reset
or immediate immediately end the cycle
meaning they're kind of like a wipe like
what if I you know I mean what if I
actually like do you think it actually
wipes what they learn though well I can
utilize it as a wipe
okay we're like I didn't do much that
last time I like crouched I think I did
a little sprinting and then I hit it
meaning now it's got it this cycle
became pretty easy okay you can kind of
wade out may be a difficult cycle or
like go back to that area after you like
had a real bad run and then hit it boss
brown sugar that is basically they said
this is actually a really good game that
won't be appreciated by a lot of people
it's probably kind of choose probably
also why we're trying to showcase it a
little bit to get it out there put it
try to put it out more people's radars
Rob really loves it in the office
same with Peter yeah Peter actually has
Peter and I uh Peters been in TGS Tokyo
but I know Mike was kind of like a
non-believer at first he wasn't really
liking it and then he kind of got to a
point where he was like okay this is
like a great ballgame but yeah I mean
it's not gonna be for everyone obviously
like you don't like puzzle games by not
for you but at the same time if you're
interested again on sale on Steam oh
nice reactions yeah luckily yeah you can
you can get like well like your your
shove can be multi-directional doesn't
have to be like forward-facing so I can
like in any direction I can kind of like
you know judging by the HUD I can kind
of tell like how close they are in
proximity and like kind of time
something like right here I can do it
that's good that it's not it's not like
clunky then right right well hi how are
you max ring thing no I bought this we
have reviewed it I'm trying to do a
video review of it today oh [ __ ]
stamina it's also available on God
Suzanne thank you for that
got an eight and if we need to adjust in
Clarkie review use a show all right now
I use the riot gun this is risky I'm
sorry the riot
yeah that's non-lethal so I Shaw saying
I like it the hood yeah I love the HUD
so I can I have this ability to scan but
then I lose the HUD for a period yeah
yeah it was just in Clark oh there's a
harp I could have played these are like
these replies to all your cells these
like bigger orbs and there are elevators
so that's the same case tunes on DIA
please thank you I hate when they sprint
do that at night I swear to god that's
for it at night oh my god oh so you
gotta get one more key right yeah and I
shook it is currently on gamespot calm
if you like I got that review the
written review and then Rob might be
doing a video review if people want to
see another area I can move around sure
they're not really
yeah then every spoiler the only
spoilery aspect is like the setting so
we can see like different types of level
design and style oh there's a heartbeat
that i are you will not make it this
often plate might not work
gonna shoot felt behind me huh oh man
they just unload I didn't save for a
while no it's fine I mean we can show
another area house dude we're gonna do
it anyways so I'm not sure about a Mac
release row Janet [ __ ] next
I wish Mac release more games Mac string
thinks I said I find it a little easy
though I have to run on hard without HUD
for it to be fun don't you say it though
trust me trust me oh yeah well I'm just
sucked in no ask him ask him if he
thought ball if he had trouble with ball
next ring did you have trouble with the
ballroom well there's a delay so I can't
trust him he just I don't know I think
was because I had a couple of beers
enemy but ballroom ballroom was like it
totally did I love this area yeah yeah
yeah see I mean like it the settings
change like that's that's a cool-looking
area let's let's stick to this bridges
bridges well as the purpose of the
instrument says Gonzalo and as
distractions so there are areas where
like there are a whole group of of these
echoes and I mean you can do you can do
a multiple multitude of things to like
alert them away she I can shouting like
this yeah we're like no a whisper
Candler just one but the intruments are
great because they kind of take longer
and they'll like you know you what I say
it you play an instrument when the light
cycles ends and then starts up again
they will walk towards instruments but
they're closed so it's like what I could
tell to when you played the piano versus
when they play the piano I feel like she
did it for almost twice as long as you
did
so it definitely looks like a good way
for you know to distract these echoes
yeah oh dang
so saying Brad shoemaker beat ballroom
on hard I don't know
give me making a note of it you know I
believe it ballroom was tough you know
it doesn't matter I don't you know it's
her own personal pride it's fun I don't
need a [ __ ] I'm not a huge puzzle guy I
hate puzzles
I shoot things in the face so this is an
area that I thought was like for me it
was one of those like I got this like
breeze through the last one and then I
got here and I'll just let it play out
and you'll kind of understand I'm gonna
ask what I'm pretty sure I know the
answer but a random guy X lol asking do
the echoes unlearn the previous actions
yes so like I do I play a cycle they
learn from it new cycle incorporates
that cycle when that second cycle ends
the first cycle wipes so so they don't
keep everything no it was only two
cycles right right oh so I'm so sorry -
oh man was it Matt Marcel I think I told
him that like they just like keep
everything it sounds like it's two
cycles worth okay mmhmm right is that
understanding correctly it's like two
light cycles worth right if that makes
sense like so the the previous cycle is
incorporated in the next one the third
cycle after that the first cycles wipes
okay the cycle you're in is only
determined by the previous cycle so this
area I was like wow there's just one
person walking around this is a no big
deal right what's up Luke Hartman and
guess what I just taught him how to open
bridges and last one because yeah when
this happened I was like oh God
so this is kind of like that when you
open it it's like the same almost the
same
as the doors thing right yeah but it's
more than that it's like that this might
seem maybe a little like obvious so they
can just like toss in mechanic but there
are areas and there are strategies that
like it's like math design looks like a
corridor or it's like or like they're
they're scattered in a way that like
force you to do different mechanics like
it's it can get real intricate and it
can like can mess with like how you've
been playing the game and that's why I
like a lot questions he's not hurt you
okay now I really want to try out the
way for the ps4 very cool glad that's
got your interest and ok again them you
know if it's twenty dollars in Steam I
would expect the same for ps4 again oh
well it was a sale from like $25 I
thought and I think it's absolutely
worth it you know again our our reviewer
beat in seven hours I'm on like our 10
or plus and I haven't been finished it
yet and I again that there's like a
locked difficulty that I would imagine
that like you can there's hard and I
think there's maybe even like an insane
difficulty or like maxford convention
hard with no hood right you can do that
I could do that now we could try it
Melodyne privately gonna try this game
it's a breath of fresh air
do you really watch I know honey yeah I
did so I said this is why I think that
cuz it's like locked game mode Oh game
mode I don't know what that means
I thought it was HUD that was here's
head but I just wonder what game mode
could mean don't know maybe you got a
beat a time like that so so that's the
locks as well so let's try hard or yeah
no man no HUDs gonna be tough try not
gonna know when you're out of stamina
good luck are you set to initial
no that's just back to what you had it
on right odo huh good go all right
restarting the level of no HUD and on
hard mildly worried this is actually
kind of tough area to I believe like the
music - so this is that stuff I could
probably
Rek that one I think the character
design is cool it's like almost eerie
how lanky she is you know like her lens
toast man X saying I can't imagine how
well the ending of this game will be and
it's Chris Pereira some Chris yeah I
hope I hope the ending is speaking
across the bridge now and then like not
trigger anything or does it have to be
doing like some things don't so that
doesn't look like these are on okay man
I forget what door it is there's a door
that I have to cross not to a good start
alright well
so yeah for those of you just tuning in
or if you just happen to start changing
so much place I go and it is essentially
a sci-fi horror puzzle game maybe not
that poor but definitely it has four
elements when I pushed you I'm a very
honest and I have that they'll I guess
they leave that on that's not like to
know HUD then I mean I don't know where
she is right now yeah she's coming
that's actually kind of cool though like
so like now you don't have the luxury of
having something tell you oh right
things are exactly
Oh for sure and now you think about like
how earlier I was saying like oh like
someone's sneaking up behind me after
teaching them how to like choke me out
like hasn't been a problem cuz I have
yeah I have that like I'm so here I have
that ability to you know always like
yeah flip it and and push away but now
it's like I have no idea if someone's
behind me here we go I know this area
yeah this this is this one takes a while
great
I mean I probably heard any like new any
other new mechanics in this area or they
kind of just lending on what you've
learned already interests like oh that's
kind of you the blue Spears so yeah this
is another part like you'll come across
T so I have to collect like a bunch in
order to engage the elevator in a minute
in the middle to go oh that's this these
these are always like kind of think I
don't wanna confirm but like a lot of
these are like in the end of a chapter
or like you engage like the master
elevator to go like again like 500
kilometers down to my destination I know
horse package 9 there is a story Rob
said is a little light but it does make
things make sense yes it does tell a
story yeah like the drive you have to
like get through like I'm really dying
to get through and see the end and
hopefully that is a payoff worthwhile
but because you said there's a couple
beats in the story they know how to
murder now sees it these are these are
key Eric I know we'll see you there and
they also spot yeah that's how that's
really cool though it was visually cool
yeah that's what - well it's it yeah
it's cool because like this is kind of
like a bland environment right but yeah
blue globes very lights she like look at
she likes though blue orbs she's in
trance I wish I could push someone off
pretty cool
he hasn't been a goo but he's aroused 9
to 10 hours sevens close so if I take
about 11 so I'm probably like a couple
hours out again that's just mean you
know some people are clearly better than
me at this game I'd be kind of like also
exploring trying to get those like whoa
doll
Ranko trying to get those um those Forks
that's like kind of tuning forks I've
been hitting those are like like the
world collectibles yeah this doesn't do
anything but trying to get those core
exceeds yeah I've been like hitting like
95 92 percent completion for each each
level so it's like there's a couple oh
yeah there's a couple I'm missing what
was the worst grade you got I went
through its like wow I've been doing 99
like Oh like always over a 90% I feel
like but again I didn't like really
looking around for him so how are you
feeling on the no hug this is the first
time you played no HUD right well am i
right yeah I haven't really had but I
guess there hasn't been a sticky
situation there has not
she's actually trying to open - I think
you just did well earlier I don't think
I did I guess
yeah Melodyne the key won her back is
part of the story it's kind of the crux
of why you're doing what you're doing is
supposed to be loved one that you're
trying to bring back to life and
apparently coming here to this planet
that we're on although this is yeah
palette but we're on a planet the hope
yeah the whole planet oh that was stupid
the whole planet is a just palace like
you see some really cool visuals of like
just infinite hallways it's pretty neat
make sure you but again did like crowd
control so if you yeah again three it
takes three echoes to like kill you so
look at I think this is the purpose so
now I haven't done anything in this in
this cycle sort of information so now
like might even get wipes this site it
has like that's the has to be the
reasoning for it so now it's like a
clean cycle where they don't know how to
do anything they're just dumb yep big
dumb today one day one yeah that's
perfect
here we go go play a little piano
[Music]
so now next time this should technically
be a saucy rift and it'll save will save
this also helps me spot I was better at
spotting the tuning forks but like it
seems to be seems to work for tuning
forks that are like in a closer
proximity Lionel horse package 9 in
switch has hanging this game looks a lot
like the movie the cell with Jennifer
Lopez the cell and I was thinking about
2001 Space Odyssey 1 right yeah so one
all-time favorite e2 is yet in the end
it's a we again we talked about doves
and he said yeah they were they were
kind of heavily inspired by that ending
scene were like you know the character
basically like goes it's like an
alternate dimension we're like
everything is so you know meticulously
meticulously like clean and white and
pristine to the name I can't read and
twitchchat because I believe it's it's
kanji so I can't I can't tell there but
it says so when the lights go out is
that one that your enemies learn
something yeah when they end when they
Palace has learned enough that it'll
then trigger the night cycle so he's
opened some doors he's played the piano
so after that they it goes dark and then
yeah I did some stealth but here in the
these blackouts where it's like
right over I can do whatever I want in
the end the no consequences yeah
anything goes hi
so now save great well you know it's a
bummer those like so I the piano I did
last time actually doesn't work anymore
I learned at open doors right
don't mind me just gonna get a couple
keys in okay Boop
screw it nope go ammo thanks event
probably better that you didn't it's
probably better than I do yeah like
again like not seeing the rag doll like
battered but it's been having a lot
during the stream he bounced it off that
table yeah I mean that'd be cool you do
like head slams into the table that yeah
push up railings others tuning for it so
yeah like I'm close enough we not see
you I mean 88 all kinda looks the same
at some point but
I know if I hurt someone yeah there's
someone definitely coming I don't know
their time remanence the norrbagge they
basically asked are you murdering your
time reminisce like the flash now do you
why there are echoes of you yeah okay
cool it's cool that's like one of the
coolest foils I have yep I have 100 good
push good push push
so like you can line up yeah tough to do
right behind me huh how old is this game
three days three days old yes come
generator we were playing on PC right
now currently on sale on Steam and I
don't know if we can get on GOG the
PlayStation version won't come out talks
over my name is Ryder okay cool yeah
this game was done by the former hitman
developers from IO Interactive now that
company is called ultra ultra this is
their first game
oh you saying man what if only the
hitman games enemies could learn what
you knew or do I don't know how they
would set that up though right
maybe I got like a level of robots
almost has to be like that
max rinks yeah
Rob did address that is something that
the reviewer also mentioned which is
that the environments are a little bit
can get a little bit bland but uh they
do change subtle like subtly but it does
look like you're kind of in the same
type of area but so I can see why people
could be yeah I could see that too
but it changes enough like again like
earlier it's like for me at least it's
like you know a pristine white to like
this kind of teal marble and then I
showed later in the stream the dark area
right there's like some underworld dark
stuff that looks that actually looks
real to uh stark but like oh man I know
there's like I really do think the
palace is a character we're like because
it's changing and there's a reason why
it's changing like there's this one area
where it's like [ __ ] just gets real
different I don't want to spoil hosting
or ho sighing okay it's roughly seven to
eight is about how much the reviewer
took Rob's we playing about yeah but
he's been trying to get more of those
tuning forks some of those side
collectables so just explore anymore so
I think it's it's probably roughly
around I do wish yeah I do if the tuning
fork for easier to find because you know
it is a fair point that it's kind of the
same kind of the same environment that
they like it that is true like a lot of
same architecture so it kind of gets
exhausting to like look in every nook
and cranny you know I mean if you're
just like looking at kind of the same
stuff try this out actually I don't know
how I do that oh I could do this though
Lionel hoard packaged as Rob
this is it big fan of big fan of the
winter so the only thing that has
impressed me so far is your voice acting
and overall sound design the game takes
weight yeah that's yeah that has been a
complaint is it is a slow burn like
again we showed her earlier and the
first part of the stream there are these
outside areas actually are visually
different they're kind of meant to like
have a lot of story but also take a
break from this environment I want to
say but there is an opening like our
that is long and it feels a little
boring but it's a lot of heavy-handed
setting and voice acting but I'll I
actually really liked it it was I mean
it was kind of long but it was really
setting I think you know yeah well to
like the meat of the game which is what
you're looking at and so my prayer I
would say if you've made it through two
hours obviously I mean I'm gonna guess
that you're playing but definitely keep
playing because it's Michael Hardy
pretty much went through the same thing
he was telling rob like hey you know I
don't I don't think this games as hot as
you are making it founded to be right
and then he finally kind of got past
that kind of opening area as you had
mentioned we kind of like the opening
trudge a little bit and he was like nope
okay just Game Freak oh I mean just and
that's unfortunate a little bit but you
know hey if like I said if you kind of
got that far hopefully you can stick it
out a little bit longer and hopefully
you get that pay off and then that keeps
you playing the rest of the game
come we're at ETSU saying the concept
with this is pretty interesting nothing
like I've seen before that's how I feel
I can't think of any other game [ __ ]
that's that like has worked my brain in
a way of like everything I'm doing is
like impacting and it is a consequence
so when you like when you do the panic
like you have those panic moments like
where you're just trying to stay alive
they're they're worse because this when
you're not remembering you're doing too
many things at once like shooting and
you're like God the next cycle is gonna
suck because I like had like a fright
like you know like a fluster of moves
and it wasn't being like crafty I find
those really interesting
Oh then do much though I hate food on
the left can you raise your mic Vanya
really uh I'll try I mean I pretty much
have never had an echo like it remembers
me definitely uh knocking someone dead
with one those orbs burner like I've
seen them pick them up I've never seen
him do it to me oh really
that actually is interesting then cuz
like if you just threw that one and hit
her I'm surprised that they don't throw
it at you if I let's find a safe I'm
down alike see if that is possible
because they're supposed to mimic
everything you do right yeah technically
she has won her hand oh yeah
thrown at us there's a safe now I wanna
get to a save max too late cuz there's
three of them
hey you're definitely lower than Rob
yeah well I'm not I'm just not
enunciated I think I maybe I just have
to turn it up the board in general I
feel like someone must have lowered it
or something because it's only been
happening recently yes alright so I
gotta go bottom floor looks like there's
a lot there okay you don't have to get
all of them I think I feel like you just
got to get it like throw them out
what's up Kumar would she'll say like oh
you're halfway there nope oh wait what's
51:16
maybe that's what it is that is what it
is it's copy
do you have 51 or you have 16 I need I
need 51 no way let's find out
best thing maybe well maybe they don't
like oh yeah you do need 50
Wow really 50 to go rob
luckily there are areas like here so
it's interesting there's a I have to do
something in order to get up to those
two
it's kind of cool
so they lower all again yeah that
happens a lot so that's not actually I
forgot that's a whole nother mechanic
it's like you can only do certain things
when it's blacked out just so you guys
know to uh if you if you're just tuning
in one this is the game echo and two
they're actually normally is a HUD that
he's not using we're playing in no HUD
mode so normally it's not necessarily as
difficult as it is right now because the
HUD actually tells you where some of
these enemies are but you're gonna have
to start all over if you turn on the
hood maybe that's just for the
difficulty okay so but we are playing on
how hard okay so you're right okay so
he's got the HUD back could you just use
the scam though I didn't well that's a
good sprint thanks max ring nope
hopefully she doesn't notice sure corner
white where he just said I just tuned in
sorry to make you repeat yourself but
yeah basically this is a puzzle game
that has it's a sci-fi puzzle game with
horror elements it's more of the
suspense element and kind of just the
creepiness of all these clones that
learn what you do at least from like two
light cycles there's a light and a dark
cycle the light cycles what he's in
right now he has to do certain things to
progress through each level and to in
order to engage into a dark cycle he has
do certain things and the palace will
then learn and teach the echoes those
things do you leave me alone but in the
dark psychology you can technically do
whatever you want right in the kill and
they won't they won't remember that all
right I get all the blue orbs and Spore
I think so so he for this area right now
he needs to get four more these blue
speared 45 more of these blue spheres
that are kind of all around the map in
order to progress yeah
but yeah like that's kind of the general
gist sorry if that wasn't as cohesive as
it needed to be so look at us so I play
to play the piano last time and they're
like scrambling Oh fair game I feel like
Kitty balls take your shirt as baller
Thanks it's a Craig Sager shirt donated
for a good cause I know horse Packers
saying my god I just found out there
will be something happening with Red
Dead 2 next week is that true hopefully
it's not fake news hopefully not dude so
last night I was having dinner with my
family and then my set that was like you
know just looking at like news and
breaking news and he's like oh my god
they're closing down the dollar store
like when I step system I'm like a chain
readout yeah they freaked out they're
like what great oh that's a cheap meant
that was dope
it turns out the dollar stores not
closing down in those big news
so oh that would be oh man that was such
an awesome place as a kid it's still a
great place it's still buying a lot of
stuff oh absolutely yeah tastes [ __ ]
rocking it thanks thanks thanks everyone
for tuning in oh they learn to shoot
people now not nope not here no no I
mean I was okay I thought that that's
what I was saying like incoming fire
it's not incoming fire
oh so that was still the molasses oh
yeah you're right
how much is this game in the Oh Pedro
asks currently honest it on sale on
Steam for twenty-two it's not sure if
it's on sale on GOG I haven't looked it
up but it's awesome GOG it'll also be on
PlayStation for back Patrick that is
funny
next next month in October not sure if
they'll be on sale it could be $30 not
sure what's happening with Red Dead it
was just someone in twitch chat saying
that there might be something news next
week I'll have to look that up later you
know what it is Eric it's not 41 it's
just I need six more I think okay there
are art that that's how many are left
yes looking for more and kids set that
to and I miss and I'm yeah
misinterpreted what he meant by that
what's up BB danger it's a long name
okay oh that's a blackout so I gotta
wait for this thing to lower and then
I'm good
oh hi how are you some people are like
talking about the repetitiveness of this
but I think that you're just seeing one
level and you're not necessarily seeing
all the intricacies of like what you're
having to deal with or think about which
is sure and what Rob does is a conch
becomes a potential consequence for him
and he's having to think that through
for the next phase right essentially
yeah wait yeah and like I'm not I'm not
gonna lie to you like it is somewhat
repetitive but like the reward of what
you're doing like again you're finding
yourself like it's like I swear it's
using your brain like a very different
way than as far as as far as like gaming
in general I I've never thought about
like how I was playing in any other game
before and that is absolutely engrossing
and like engaging like it's it is in
that respect really fun to play so just
on the Red Dead 2 front Rockstar
apparently tweeted out that on the 28th
they're gonna be doing something
something's happening with Red Dead news
so the next Thursday it looks like we
might get some red stuff
oh boo yeah is that gonna be a stream
then No
hard to say it depends on what it is I
guess man I'm willing to bet this is an
achievement to get all these things
balls yeah I can see that or maybe even
something else all right let's get down
I don't know why actually you know I
still wanted to do maybe we can find a
save
nearby
you definitely didn't throw it that one
time right they don't think they'll
throw it I think they might not happy
with it maybe I would hope so but well
they were definitely chasing you what
they remember yeah oh yeah they
definitely pick it up although I guess
they probably wouldn't hit you with it
because they probably do the same
animation of like grabbing you that's
what I was thinking today like I think
they'd probably one-hit ko you cuz that
is all they really do I can't be that
can be annoying though right like don't
pick it up meaning I can't use it I'm
trying to get down but this is good okay
good
Paul I'm saved so they're not just a
one-time use thing okay oh no for sure
yeah I can like go through those but
like this there's so many funny moments
I've had where it's like I think I'm in
the clear I'm gonna make it an elevator
but it's like in the previous cycle I
have used an elevator and I'll catch one
elevator and like an echo will like be
there at the elevator I'm trying to get
to like comes down and I'm just like oh
great kills me
take me down one more nope you determine
down oh she's gonna be here now Oh
surprise what oh my nice shoot him I was
gonna shoot how are you what Mike chose
not working I can't turn okay we're
gonna minor technical difficulties we'll
see if he's okay now what he is man I
will say like oh you will say what why
don't you play mouse keyboard I'm just
kidding
controlling
you cannot turn right right now this is
weird because I don't think this has
happened to him this time but I've had
I've had controller to bookies with this
game I'm just really frustrating let's
do this by another Xbox controller sure
give it a go see if it works well we are
having a Z saying the next area as a
pain in the ass we have a save so let's
do that
I'm just reloaded
through this controllers way better well
I came with the Xbox one it s the slim
well that makes sense
I almost said X but I was like there we
go
weird I was weird so this is down oh it
looks like it's down huh figured it out
rod look at the textures show me the way
yeah thank you guys all for tuning in
yeah we're checking out EKKO kind of fun
cool game you guys should check out if
you're into puzzle sci-fi with night
horror with a smack of heart to it yeah
suspense I'm gonna go with suspense or
thriller yeah not really like you're not
scared it's like more like a mental I
mean I'm a wuss about having good jump
scares why are you come down with me
that's fair piece what maybe during
night you can't go through that was
weird but yeah like we are live every
day at 11 a.m.
there's flies so if you haven't so you
can find out you get notifications when
we go live also because we're making
some cool content we're gonna have like
a NBA 2k versus live face scan thing up
later today yeah that's very funny okay
so here I got enough while it's clear
[ __ ] I got
as cliche Rob's in deep thought he's
reading right now these are like super
like ambiguous but like they do mean
something like that was interesting I
don't like each level has one again if I
kind of tuning forks hit then that'll
like oh no it's a story 116 km/h
yeah this is so like if you notice the
palace is changing now oh is this like
heading into the next region yeah this
is the next chapter cool
is there anything like I won't say much
but like is there more stuff you want to
show up or do you think there anything
that you didn't get to show off for
showcase I'm just curious because it
seems like a pretty good yeah yeah I
don't I don't like that long side that
you just made this was really very
revealing well this was really scary
when I sat down here now
scary should I do it shut it down
I mean it is like you know alright Chad
do you want to see what scared Rob put
the ones in the chat if you don't and
you want us to stop showing stuff put
the twos in the chat and I want any of
you I'm gonna give you like your minute
or two from delay I don't think I could
be wrong oh man you can't let me set the
chat up like that and then like not be
no that's awful ones for yes two for no
and we should wrap it up on cuz I don't
know that's why I asked like if you had
anything else like special that you
thought that you might want to show I
might have you showed off I'm sorry I
had seen a couple ones ones or twos one
is yes two is no I'm gonna give 30 more
seconds I like think but I could be
wrong with the fact that the person said
since it a lot of people are saying sit
let's just do it all right Rob you
better not be wrong yeah
nope I'm right they all are just [ __ ]
come in are they app is that was that
kind of was that that bad that wasn't
that bad ah so the only reason why that
was so uneventful huh I mean you play
the game so I will just at least frame
it in that like did you you you do that
a lot
all right you sit a lot you say you do
that trigger doors open so like when
that happened I remember like thinking
over hype for sure
sorry I just remember like what I felt
was like late at night that happen I was
like oh my god you know whatever playing
in the dark I could totally see that
scary yeah I had a bad feeling that I
had this feeling that there was gonna be
this big setup and we working at the
payoff what a great way to end your
showing here before I kind of go back to
cool camera no man I mean that's alright
let's watch this let's play out here I
think you're good right I'm going to
camera unless you don't think you're
good
no that's it I'm sorry all right cool
but yeah thanks so much Rob for playing
is showing off showing off HECO the
sci-fi puzzle light horror game I'm
gonna let you have your I'm gonna do
this like this ESPN thing like they do
these podcast talk shows we're like when
the person wins the day you get you let
them have a good couple of minutes to
kind of tell them all about this game
and why they should play it because you
know you're you're super stoked about
this one and want more people to try it
and play it right yeah I I would say
like of all the games I've ever played
this one like I'm a huge sci-fi fan I
like Star Wars
go figure like from the second if you
like sci-fi as much as I
which is I know however you want to
gauge that but like from the start to
like even now it's been super gratifying
and in every fashion inform like I'm
engaged I can see the complaints for
like you know you know it's kind of
boring it's kind of the same thing I
don't know I think if you care enough
about like cool game mechanics in like
thinking differently about how you play
like that like risk reward that
consequence of everything you're doing
is like flipped and turned back and
upside down like it's just like it's
been super engaging I think the price is
you know for steam again ps4 later on
we'll see how much a district ps4 I
would still think it would be less than
$30 I it's been like definitely worth it
I think anyone is even remotely
interested in this I think you should
give a shot for sure it's gratifying
again you can like go back and replay
like any mission you don't have to like
start the whole game from scratch
hopefully this like insane mode I really
I want a fish to see with like the
whatever game-mode or didn't seem too
bad no actually yeah from watching you
play I might have noticed like a subtle
like difficulty bump but it wasn't like
oh crap like you like you know what I
mean like it didn't seem overwhelming I
guess yeah but maybe insane is pretty
crazy but yeah thank you guys all for
tuning in
we're live every day at 11 GameSpot live
so come back Monday we have Destiny's
children was out today from the UK folks
that's our destiny kind of like destiny
to long play kind of stuff and then we
also do that on Tuesdays here in the US
it's me Rob and John Luke we kind of
cycle through and of course we have
lobbies on Wednesday but yeah stay tuned
to all the cool stuff coming out Rob
might be doing an echo review the
written review is up by Justin Clark
already that so go ahead and read that
got an 8 out of 10 so yeah if you're
interested in this game hopefully you go
try it and until next time thank you
guys all and see you later have a good
weekend see you guys happy Friday
you